chris is with us in Texas hi Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
oh thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um so I'm currently in
Community College I will be obtaining my
associates degree in Business
Administration this coming fall
good my mother wants me to transfer to a
four-year university to obtain my
bachelor's and business finances but I'm
having doubts I'm not having that
thinking about a 30k in student loan is
worth it as of now I don't have any
savings for college tuition so I've told
my mother that I wanted to UM take a
break from school work save up some
money down attend college as a minimum
that as much as possibly can and sees
that liking the idea of there and I was
wondering how I should approach this how
old are you I'm 20 years old okay well
it's on I'm glad that your mom's
concerned about you and that's a good
thing but the fact that she's saying you
should go into debt and you're not
wanting to go into debt means that
you're gonna have to go your own way and
lovingly explain to your mom you're just
not gonna do that
so why 30,000 I have about three years
that you had her so I thought you had a
two-year associate's won't that cover
your first two years of college I does
but I don't plan on taking that 12
credit hours instead of 14 or 16 core
hours like the college recommends per
year so I calculated it with three three
year my calculation because if I am in
college in two years
I did I did that while in Community
College and that sort of play the role
into it I'm looking at about 3.5 to
three years to finish my bachelor's up
what about $9,000 per year why does it
take three years to finish a bachelor's
when you've already done two years in
work you should only have two year
left okay shouldn't you why are you
taking three years to do two years for
the work I'm not sir okay I don't I
don't want to take a 15 watt credit
hours because a normal load if I do go
to the University I'll have to take it
out Harman and my parents are not
financially able to help me with living
expenses over there so I would have to
take a full-time job on top of that some
of my pita friends that did it take 16
credits 617 credit hours while hiding
the full-time job we're not able to
concentrate fully on school so I figured
taking 12 credit hours and having a
full-time job would be able to sustain
my living conditions and still have
enough time to focus on schoolwork well
I graduated I graduated in four years
and I worked 40 hours a week okay so
that's what's running through my head
I mean I'm and I got a degree in finance
you know so which is what you're
studying so you're you're we're in Texas
now I'm in Austin Texas okay and you're
wanting to go to school where it's not
Marcos Texas State okay and what's wrong
with the University of Texas and Austin
I did apply to the I wasn't able to go I
was accepted into it you're great I
suppose so I do have a 3.0 GPA I'm not
exactly too sure why I was the
application was denied I was never told
it reason why because they're another
another school another four-year school
in Austin that you could attend I
suppose there's a st. Edwards University
what did the private school okay I don't
I mean is there another state schooling
other than UT there in Austin not that
I'm aware of
okay all right so you're talking about
moving and going to where San Marcos
it's about two hours south of Austin
okay and is that a is that a state
school as well ed of the state
mm guy all right and it's $9,000 a year
yes okay so for two years you'd need
$20,000 and you could work and earn that
and earn your living expenses I think
you can work your way through but you're
not going to have much of a life for the
next two years all you're gonna do is
work and go to school which is by the
way all I did I mean I didn't have a
huge college party experience it was you
know we were we worked all the time and
so but I got through and I paid for it
you know so if you're going to move to
San Marcos that's what I would do with
the other thing I'd do is always make
another run at UT because you could live
there at home and that would save you a
ton of expenses and UT is you know
around that same price I don't remember
exactly what it was University of Texas
and Austin but I would go over and visit
someone at the admissions office and try
to find out you know why you weren't
accepted if you've got a 3.0 GPA that
should have gotten you in to UT and then
make sure all of your credit hours
transfer and they put yourself on a
two-year schedule live at home work your
way through and do it but no I would not
take out a $30,000 loan and no I don't
think that's necessary and no I don't
think you have to take a year off to do
this I think you can figure this out and
work your way through so I'm worse than
your mother I'm saying don't quit keep
going but don't take out a student loan
and work until your collapse and get
this with done get it figured out hey
thanks for the call